Military service definitely
has humbled me as an individual,
and it also allows you to be
more compassionate with others.
My name is Violeta Ware
and I am a Marine
and an Army veteran.
When 9/11 came, I knew that
I wanted to serve myself.
And so when I turned 17,
I received a waiver
from my parents
to enlist in the ROTC program
at Georgia Tech.
I also served,
enlisted in the Army,
and then I answered
the call in the government
and served there for six
and a half years.
I am a construction
engineer by trade,
and I function as a utilities
project manager in facilities.
The Belonging at Yale program
allows all of us an opportunity
network with each other.
There are large disparities
with veterans who come home
and fight battles
that are silent.
The struggles are internal
and we need everyone's support.
To my fellow veterans
on Veterans Day,
I encourage you guys
to share your stories
with each other and fellowship
in all of our service.